So, stochastic games, originally due to Shappley, have a bunch
of different quantities. State, actions,
transitions, rewards, and discount factors. And
here's how we're going to do it. We're going to, we're going to
say that s, little s, is, is one of the states.
And actions could be like little a, but actually, since
we're going to focus mostly on two player games for the moment,
I'm going to write actions as a and b. Where a
is an action for player one and b is an action
for player two. Sound okay?
>> Sure.
>> Alright. So next we have the transition function.
So, the transition function says: If you're in some
state, s, and there's some joint action that's taken,
like all the players choose their action simultaneously, a comma
b, then what's the probability of reaching some next
state s prime? And we can write rewards the same
way. So there's reward for player one, given that
we're in state s and there's a joint action ab.
And there's the reward for the other player, the second player.
And a discount factor is you know, like a discount factor.
>> Totally makes sense. So oh its the same discount factor for everyone.
>> Yes! Good a good point. One need not define things
that way, but in fact that is the way it's always defined.
>> Hey, not to go of on a tangent here, but sometimes I see
NDP's and things like stochastic games defined
with a discount Factor being a part
of the definition, and sometimes not. Like it's just a part of
the prob, definition of the problem or sometimes its a parameter of an
algorithm. Which do you prefer? Why do you, why haven't, why have
the discount factor actually listed as part of the definition of the game?
>> I have no justification other than it's nice to
have listed the things that might be important as oppose to
you know, working through algorithms for while and then saying,
oh yeah there's this other number that kind of matters too.
>> Okay
that's fair. I was just curious. So one of the things that I
actually find really interesting is that this model was laid out by Shapley.
>> Mm-hm.
>> One of the, like a former Nobel prize winner. I guess
once you're a Nobel prize winner, you're a Nobel prize winner forever.
>> Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
>> So, Shapley, the Nobel prize winner, and
as we're going to see in a moment, this
model is actually a generalization of MDPs, but
Shapley published it before Bellman published about MDPs.
>> Oh. This is pre-Bellman.
So MDPs, to some extent, can be thought of
as a narrowing of the definition of a stochastic game.
>> Huh.
>> So, all right. Let's do a little quiz. And see that we
really understand the relationship between this model
and other things that we've talked about.
>> Okay.